hey guys it is Friday which means I got
five of the biggest stories that came
out of the last week all ready to go for
you the games industry was devastated
this week with the news that nintendo
president satoru iwata had passed away
misurata had dealt with health issues
for at least two the past year and it
was announced by nintendo that the
well-loved CEO had passed you to a bile
duct growth on July 11 over the last
week there's been an immense outpouring
of love memories and support from a wise
as colleagues fans and fellow industry
figures undoubtedly of assets great
impact on the industry and those around
him will not soon be forgotten five
nights at Freddy's creators Scott
Cawthon certainly isn't a man who likes
to keep his fans waiting and don't think
that the fourth and final chapter of the
game would be arriving in August only
four months after the last chapter the
date of august eighth was chosen because
it's the one year anniversary of the
original five nights at freddy's release
and yes that does mean that core phone
will have released four or five nights
at freddy's games in one year he has
expressed a desire to keep this year's
halloween special however by releasing a
free update with extra content on that
date this making things that will save
you a dollar or two microsoft have
announced their latest deals with gold
offerings for xbox one you can pick up
murdered soul suspect for 12 bucks and
Tomb Raider definitive edition very very
attractive nine dollars 90 cheap games
on xbox 360 included xcom enemy Unknown
and spec ops the line the ten bucks and
750 respectively check out the full list
of deals on gamespot but be quick if
you're keen because they'll only last
until july twenty
this week's that approached red
announced the latest which a 3 DLC and
well it's an outfit for Siri which we
all already near because it leaked last
week series alternate attire is the
latest to be released after guralt
Jennifer and tris were all previously
given the ultimate look treatment the
developer have made a point of
delivering new content every week since
the game's release the only exception
being last week where they instead
worked on a major patch due to arrive
for all versions of the game the one
point 07 patch does not currently have a
concrete release date and finally a
couple of shitty things happen to her
day Okajima this week including his name
and studio being stripped off of metal
gear solid 5 the phantom pain box art
Konami appear to have gone full breakup
mode with kajima just a few days prior
snakes Japanese voice actor otsuka Akio
said Kojima Productions had been
disbanded and now there appears to be no
mention of the studio or kajima on the
official and finalized box art for Metal
Gear Solid 5 Konami had already removed
any mention of kijima from the official
Metal Gear Twitter their LA office
listing and the game's official artwork
and marketing material so this appears
to be the final nail in the coffin
unconfirmed reports also suggests konami
has muted kajima on twitter and has
changed its facebook relationship status
with kajima from in a relationship to
its complicated be sure to let me know
down in that comment box what you cared
about this week and what you think of
this Konami kijima drama this week on
site I tell you what all the herstory
fuss is about on the gist Lucy covers
off on Jade Raymond joining EA on in two
minutes and we pay tribute to cetera
waters incredible life and legacy that
is everything I have the
this week as always let me know what
mattered to you and be sure to have
yourselves a great weekend